majority' these women are here our
mothers that's why we are here that's
why most of us are out here
in his mind in his heart ever since he's
been five he's wanted to be a police
officer it shattered my son's dream
because now he does not have the same
respect that he had for police it's
changed his life a lot of people are
having sleepless nights I'm one of them
I'm just up thinking about you know what
if it were my son my brother did my
service in Fabio down tell me about
Police Battalion in Blackman and as a
mother it breaks my heart to know that I
don't know how to fix
we just want justice that's
they said that we should were equal but
are we really equal
you